اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض وهذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
البيان الختامي لمجلس التنسيق السعودي
العراقي يؤكد على توسيع وتعزيز التعاون
بين البلدين
مجلس التعاون الخليجي يجدد التاكيد على
دعمه جهود انهاء الازمه اليمنيه عبر الحل
السياسي
وفاه مبتعثه سعوديه في ولايه كانسيس
الامريكيه وقريب لها يكشف تفاصيل حادثه
غرقها
في الرابعه ايضا
جبل عكمه احد ابرز مواقع العلى التاريخيه
يدخل سجل ذاكره العالم التابع لليونسكو
ومانغو جازان تغزل الاسواق الاقليميه
باكثر من 60 صنفا من خلال مليون شجره
حياكم الله كدا البيان والختامين
الاجتماعي مجلس التنسيق السعودي العراقي
والذي عقد اليوم في جده على اهميه توسيع
وتعزيز التعاون الثنائي بين البلدين كما
اشاد البيان بجهود مجموعه اوبيك بلس في
تعزيز استقرار اسواق النفط
الجانبان اكد كذلك على الحرص على انجاز
اجراءات تنفيذ مشروع الربط الكهربائي كما
اكد عزمهما كما اكد عزمهما على رفع وتيره
التعاون الاقتصادي والاستثماري وذلك مع
تجديد العراق دعوته للشركات السعوديه
للاستثمار كما اكد الجانبان على استمرار
التعاون في مجال النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه
بين البلدين وعلى وضع تصور لتشجيع
الاستثمار السياحي بين البلدين
الجانبان اتفقا كذلك على تكثيف التعاون
وتبادل وجهات النظر حول القضايا الاقليميه
والدوليه بما يسهم في دعم وتعزيز الامن
والاستقرار وضروره ابعاد المنطقه عن
التوترات هذا وشاهد المجلس اليوم توقيع
عدد من مذكرات التفاهم في مجالات السياحه
والثقافه والاعلام والاخبار
ومثل هذه الاجتماعات تعزز العلاقات وتقرب
وتوضح الفرص وتسوق لجميع الفرص
الاستثماريه بين البلدين فنرحب بهم في
بلدهم الثاني وان شاء الله دورتنا السادسه
ستكون في في بغداد وهناك بالعديد من الفرص
الكثيره اللي تكلمنا عنها سواء في الربطه
الكهربائي في اللوجستكس في الاستثمارات
بصفه عامه
وايضا
لاحظتوا انه حجم التجاره ارتفع وصل في عام
22 الى مليار و500 مليون دولار
للعراق بيننا وبين العراق
رئيس الجانب السعودي في مجلس الاعمال
السعوديه العراقيه محمد الخريف اكد على ان
العمل جاري حاليا لايجاد مناطق اقتصاديه
او صناعيه في العراق كما يتم دراسه انشاء
منطقه اللوجستيه قرب منفذ جديده عرعر
ستساهم في تسهيل التبادل التجاري بين
السعوديه والعراق وسط التوقعات بان تصل
الصادرات بين البلدين الى عشره مليارات
دولار خلال خمس سنوات
ايجاد مناطق اقتصاديه او مناطق صناعيه في
العراق وهذا ما يبحث مع الجانب العراقي
لان حقيقه هناك مما نلمسه شح في المناطق
الصناعيه المتوفره بالخدمات المتكامله
سواء كاراضي او حمايه وامن او من الجانب
ايضا وجود الطاقه ومصادر الطاقه فهذه جزء
من الاشياء التي ايضا تضاف تبحث يعني اريد
ان انوه ايضا حكومه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مشكوره الان مطروح مناطق منطقه
لوجستيه في المنطق في قريبه من الحدود في
منطقه جزيره العرعر وهذه معروضه
للمستثمرين وهناك ايضا توجه لافتتاح هذه
المنطقه اللوجستيه التي ستخدم الحركه
التجاريه والتبات التجاريين وجود المنطقه
اللوجستيه وغيرها من المناطق بالتاكيد
انها ستساهم في تسهيل الحركه التجاريه
والتبادل التجاري بين الولدين التبادل
التجاري اليوم عند مليار ونصف
دولار ذكرت انه ارتفع ب 50%
ما هو الرقم المستهدف في المرحله ربما هذا
العام وفي المرحله المقبله
نحن طبعا هناك يعني خطه متكامله
تقودها هيئه تنميه الصادرات ومن خلال ايضا
الاشراف المباشر من مجلس التنسيقي للوصول
الى مستوى من الصادرات يصل الى عشره مليار
دولار باذن الله نحن نطمح ان نكون خلال
رؤيه
سمو العهد خلال العشره خلال الخمس سنوات
القادمه باذن الله
ايضا على هامشي اجتماعي مجلس التنسيق
السعودي العراقي
خالد الفالح الى اطلاق الشركه السعوديه
العراقيه للاستثمار براس مالي ثلاثه
مليارات دولار وتخصيص مليار ونصف المليار
دولار للصندوق السعودي للتنميه لدعم
المشاريع التنمويه وتمويل الصادرات
والواردات بين البلدين
مبادرات تنمويه كبرى
اهمها هو اطلاق سيدي سمو ولي العهد الامير
محمد بن سلمان رئيس مجلس اداره الصندوق
الاستثمارات العامه لشركه استثماريه
مهمه جدا هي الشركه السعوديه العراقيه
للاستثمار ملكيه كامله لصندوق الاستثمارات
العامه براس مال ثلاثه مليار دولار
ستنطلق قريبا اعمالها اسست قانونيا
وستنطلق اعمالها قريبا ان شاء الله
للاستثمار في العراق في مشاريع استراتيجيه
بكلها اثر كبير وتجذب ايضا هذه المشاريع
اللي بقودها الاستثمارات العامه
مستثمرين اخرين من المملكه خارج المملكه
عندنا ايضا صندوق السعودي للتنميه خصص لوم
مليار و500 مليون منها مليار لاعاده
الاعمار
وتم التعرف على عده مشاريع تم توقيع
اتفاقيات فيها ونطمح ان شاء الله للتعجيل
بتخصيص كامل المليار لمشاريع تنمويه اخرى
500 مليون دولار عند صندوق السعودي
للتنميه لتمويل الصادرات والواردات
المتبادله بين البلدين ونامل ان شاء الله
ان يتم الاستفاده من كامل هذا المبلغ هذا
طبعا جزء بسيط من الطموحات
والفرص التي نعتقد انها متاحه بالذات بين
شركات
القطاع الخاص من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اللي نحفزها وبكون لها اليوم تواجد كبير
في المنتدى
الاقتصادي وبنسمع منها ان شاء الله مشاريع
طموحها في العراق
الحقيقه يعني تاتي اهميه انعقاد المجلس
التنسيقي العراقي بدورته الخامسه في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في جده في ظل
تحديات تواجه العالم وتواجه المنطقه قسم
منها سياسيه وقسم منها
بيئيه وتغيرات مناخيه انطلاق هذا المجلس
لهذا العام استطيع ان اقول انه في اوج
وافضل حالات العلاقه بين الدولتين
الشقيقتين تاسس هذا المجلس كما تعلمون منذ
6 سنوات باكوره اعمال هذا المجلس اعتقد
بدات تتوج الان
النوايا حقيقيه والشراكه حقيقيه لانطلاق
في كل المجالات الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
والاستثمار على كل المستويات وان كانت
الزراعيه او الصناعيه او قطاع
البتروكيماويات والطاقه والطاقه المتجدده
نتامل لهذا المجلس ان يؤسس نموذجا لشراكه
حقيقيه تحتوي بها دول المنطقه لكي نستطيع
ان نواجه التح ديات التي تواجه المنطقه
وخاصه منطقه العربيه من جده يلتحق بنا
مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد
المحسن مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشاط
الرابعه من الرياض ابرز ما تضمنه البيان
الختامي الاجتماعات ايضا
لمجلس التنسيق السعودي العراقي
والاجتماعات ايضا المصاحبه عليها مشهد
الاجتماع الذي تم فيه
نعم نايف بالفعل كان هنالك اجتماعات مطوله
ومكثفه منذ بدء صباح هذا اليوم حيث بدا
المجلس التنسيقي السعودي العراقي وبدا
اجتماعاته عند الساعه الحاديه عشره بتوقيت
جده ليعقد اجتماعه في دورته الخامسه
ويستعرض ابرز نتائج التوصيات الصادره من
اللجان العامله في هذا المجلس وهي تقريبا
ثمانيه اللجان تتنوع ما بين اللجان
السياسيه والامنيه وكذلك الاقتصاديه
وغيرها من اللجان التي تعمل على رفع
التوصيات بشكل مباشر لاعتمادها من قبل
المجلس وبعد ذلك تم التوقيع عدد من
الاتفاقيات تتحدث عن ثلاثه اتفاقيات في
قطاع السياحه والاعلام وكذلك قطاع الارشفه
بالاضافه لذلك كان هناك تصريحات لافته
نايف تتحدث عن تطور هائل في العلاقات
الاقتصاديه بين البلدين هنالك حديث كبير
عن منفذ جديده عرعر تصريحات مختلفه من
المسؤولين الذين قالوا بان هذا المنفذ
ساهم بشكل كبير برفع عمليه التبادل
التجاري الى ان وصلت الى مليار ونصف الم
دولار خلال العام الماضي واو رقم يتصاعد
بشكل كبير مع التاكيد على ان هذا الرقم
لازال يعني هم يطمحون بان يكون هذا الرقم
اعلى بكثير ولكن بدايه مبشره بحسب وصفهم
بالاضافه الى الحديث عن ابرز المشاريع
التي تم العمل عليها من قبل الشركات
السعوديه وتحديدا نتحدث عن شركات الكبرى
وشركات الطاقه التي دخلت الى السوق
العراقيات تحدث عن شركه ارامكو واكوا باور
شركه ارامكو تحديدا تعمل على بحسب ما
تحدثنا مع وزير الاستثمار السعودي خالد
الفالح الذي قال بان شركه ارامكو تعمل على
تطوير احد الحقول النفطيه بشراكه مع
العراق بالاضافه الى ان اكوا باور تعمل مع
شركاء في العراق على تطوير والاستفاده من
الغاز المحروق لانتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه
في العراق بالاضافه الى عدد من الشركات
التي تعمل هنالك ايضا كان هنالك حديث
اليوم في مجلس الاعمال السعودي العراقي
الذي ضم اكثر من 300 شركه شاركت بشكل
مباشر من قبل الرؤساء التنفيذيين للشركات
السعوديه والعراقيه تحدثوا عن ابرز تحديات
التي تواجه قطاع الاعمال في الطرفين وكان
هناك ايضا حديث من رئيس الوفد العراقي
محمد تميم رئيس النائب رئيس مجلس الوزراء
ورئيس المجلس التنسيقي السعودي العراقي من
الجانب العراقي تحدث عن انه التشريعات
والقوانين التي وضعتها الحكومه العراقيه
تسهل عمل المستثمرين ويدعو المستثمرين الى
الدخول الى العراق بالاضافه الى ذلك كان
هنالك حديث لافت منه عن التطورات الجاريه
في المنطقه وتحديدا العلاقات التي تم
ابرامها ما بين السعوديه وايران وتحسين
العلاقات
بوساطه صينيه تحدث بان العراق مستعده لان
تكون منطقه ترانزيت ما بين
ما بين الحركات التجاريه السعوديه
الايرانيه وسيتم السماح بحسب حديثه بدخول
الشاحنات من ايران الى السعوديه والعكس من
السعوديه الى بالاضافه الى ذلك كان هنالك
احاديث كبيره من قبل وزير التجاره السعودي
عن دعوه المستمعين اليوم الى بلوره عدد من
المقترحات والحلول لتسهيل عمليه التبادل
التجاري ورفعها بشكل كبير جدا ومساعده
العراق فيما اذا كان هنالك امور يحتاج
فيها المساعده من قبل السعوديه بالاضافه
لذلك نايف كان هناك اجتماع اللجنه
السياسيه والامنيه
العسكريه عقد الاسبوع الماضي وتم استعراض
ابرز النتائج التي توصلت اليها كان
الاجتماع ما بين وزيري الخارجيه السعودي
والعراقي في جده الاسبوع الماضي كل هذه
الملفات تم مناقشتها سواء كان على المستوى
السياسي والامني والعسكري بالاضافه الى
التركيز على الجانب الاقتصادي بشكل مباشر
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل من جده مراسل العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي
تشهد العلاقات السعوديه العراقيه تطورا
لافتا على مختلف الاصعده ما يفتح افاقا
جديدا للتعاون في المجالات السياسيه
والامنيه والتجاريه ومجالات الطاقه من
خلال مجلس التنسيق السعودي العراقي الذي
تستضيفه جدا اليوم دورته الخامسه فمن ابرز
منجزات المجلس مشاهدينا في المجالات
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه والاستثماريه بدء
اعمال الملحقيه التجاريه السعوديه بالعراق
وتدشير شركه السعوديه العراقيه للاستثمار
وانشاء مركز في بغداد لتنميه الصادرات
السعوديه ومن المنجزات ايضا مشاهدينا دخول
اربع شركات سعوديه عملاقه السوق العراقي
في مختلف المجالات وهي ارامكو وسابك
ومعادن واكوا باور وعلى المستوى التجاري
فقد ساهم افتتاحه منفذ جديده عرعر في
تنشيط حركه التجاره بين السعوديه والعراق
حيث شكل المنفذ تحولا كبيرا واثرا ايجابيا
على حركه الحجاج والمعتم العراقيين في
الدخول الى السعوديه والذين تجاوز عددهم
اكثر من 33 الف معتمر عراقي خلال العام
الحالي منذ تاسيس مجلس التنسيق السعودي
العراقي في عام 2017 بلغ حجم تبادل
التجاري بين البلدين المشاهدين سته
مليارات ونصف المليار دولار وفي عام 20 22
قفز حجم التبادل التجاري الى مليار ونصف
المليار دولار بنسبه ارتفاع بلغت خمسين في
المئه مقارنه بالعام 20 21 اما المجال
التعليمي فقد شهد اطلاق برنامج يستهدف
تقديم مئه منحه دراسيه
لطلبه العراقيين لمده خمس سنوات في جميع
التخصصات الانسانيه والعلميه والهندسيه
والصحيه لجميع الدرجات العلميه في جامعه
السعوديه حيث تم بالفعل خلال العام الجاري
مشاهدينا قبول الدفعه الاولى من الطلبه
العراقيين لدراسه في الجامعات السعوديه
الاتفاقيات التنمويه التي قدمتها السعوديه
شهدت ايضا نموا حيث تجاوزت قيمتها 42
مليون دولار امريكي كما اعتمد بنك وتصدير
والاستيراد السعودي خطوطا ائتمانيه لمصارف
عراقيه بقيمه
مليون دولار امريكي
تشهد العلاقات العراقيه السعوديه ازدهارا
سياسيا واقتصاديا انعكس على ارض الواقع من
خلال دخول كبريات شركات المملكه الى السوق
العراقيه قبلها طرح فرص استثماريه عراقيه
في مجالات البناء والطاقه والزراعه في
اشاره ايجابيه لزياده مؤشر الميزان
التجاري بين البلدين
وتاني يوما بعد يوم هكذا يصفها الطرفان
المجلس التنسيقي العراقي السعودي المظله
التي طورت هذه العلاقه باكثر من سبع رجال
امنيه وسياسيه وعلى راسها اللجنه
الاقتصاديه
هذه المساعي ستكون في ملتقى جده بين 24 و
25 من هذا الشهر
وعند محاور كثيره منها انشاء شركه نقل
عراقيه مشتركه بين شركات العراقيه
والسعوديه
بينها تهديد عدد من مشاريع الاستثماريه
التي
يرغب الجانب العراقي في استمارها مشتركا
بين الشركات العراقيه والسعوديه
سته اعوام من التعاون والتخطيط على الورق
اصبحت واقعا ملموسا في السوق العراقي
شركات سعوديه كبرى دخلت البلاد معلنه فتح
باب الاستثمار السعودي على مصراعيه في
العراق اول شركه طبعا سابك بدت تجهز
للعراق بالمواد الاوليه بالحبيبات
بالبروكيماويات بكل المواد الاوليه اللي
تدخل بالمصانع العراقيه من ضمنها
الالمنيوم عندنا مصانع لصناعه الكانديز
الالمنيوم للعلبه المعدنيه كل المواد
الاوليه الان تدخل من منفذ عرعر
يرى مراقبون ان العلاقه بين العراق
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه في افضل
حالاتها خاصه بعد افتتاح مركز للشركات
السعوديه وسط العاصمه بغداد وان الفرص
الاستثماريه متاحه للشركات السعوديه هنا
او مركز تجاري سعودي بالعاصمه بغداد راح
يسهل عمليه التبادل التجاري والتصديري من
خلال منتجات السعوديه التي تتمتع
بالمواصفه العاليه والجوده
ولها سوق كبير وواعد بالاسواق العراقيه من
الممكن يسهل عمليه الاستيراد والتصدير
ميزان تجاري يتجاوز المليارين دولار سنويا
بحسب احصائيات شبه رسميه لكنه على ما يبدو
غير كاف ولا يلبي طموح الطرفين بالانفتاح
الاقتصادي ويحتاج الى مزيد من الفرص سامر
الكبيسي العربيه بغداد
وعلى هامش اجتماع المجلس التنسيقيه
السعودي العراقيه اكد وزير النقل السعودي
صالح الجاسر عن اهميه منفذ اجدادات عرعر
لدعم وزياده حركه التجاره بين السعوديه
والعراق التي نمت بنسبه خمسين في المئه في
العام الماضي تكامل بين البلدين منفذ
جديده عرعر الذي تم افتتاحه واصبح منفذ
للخير والنماء والتواصل بين البلدين يشهد
نمو كبير في الحركه التجاريه 50% نمو
العامل 22
ويعني بدايه هذا العام ايضا مستمره هذا
النمو حركه الحجاج والمعتمرين الان يعني
سلسه عبر المنفذ المنفذ انشئ فيه يعني
موقع لتسهيل الاجراءات الحجاج ممكن يتسع
الى 70 الف حاج ايضا المعتمرين اليوم بشكل
يومي بلغ يعني خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
يوميا يمر 6000
تمر ايضا يعني هناك عمل مشترك في ضمن
اعمال اللجنه لتعزيز الربط الجوي تم توقيع
اتفاقيات في هذا الاطار وايضا بدا تشغيل
الرحلات المباشره اليوم
شركات الطيران السعوديه بدات تسير رحلات
مباشره للعراق وخلال ما تبقى من هذا العام
سيتم مضاعفه اعداد هذه الرحلات زياده
الربط هذا سيكون له اثر في تسهيل الحركه
على المواطنين بين البلدين وزياده فرص
التبادل التجاري ايضا
هذه اكبر ساحه للتبادل التجاري في منفذ
جديده عرعر التي تم تشغيلها مؤخرا بعد ان
كانت حركه التجاره البينيه بين السعوديه
والعراق تجري في الجانب العراقي منذ عامين
اتقوم هيئه الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك في
منفذ جديده عرعر بدور كبير لتعزيز التبادل
التجاري بين بلدين الشقيقين المملكه
وجمهوريه العراق من خلال تقديم خدمات
جمركيه ذات كفاءه عاليه مع مراعاه احكام
الرقابه الجمركيه وذلك سعيا لتحقيق
مستهدفات تيسير التجاره وتمكين وصول
المنتجات السعوديه الى السوق العراقيه بكل
يسر ومرونه عبر هذا المنفذ مرت وتمر
صادرات سعوديه متنوعه الى الاسواق
العراقيه مثل الاسمنت والمواد الغذائيه
والصحيه فمنذ نوفمبر 2020 عبرت 26 الف
حافله تحمل الصادرات السعوديه الى داخل
العراق
تتم عمليه نقل البضائع من الشاحنات
السعوديه الى الشاحنات العراقيه بانسيابيه
عاليه ومن خلال الاستفاده من جميع
الممكنات التي يحظى بها المنفذ وجميع
الخدمات الجمركيه التي تقدم في المنفذ من
نقل وتحميل البضائع تقدم بشكل مجانا لجميع
الشاحنات اجراءات جمركيه اسهل عززت من نمو
الصادرات السعوديه الى العراق حيث بلغت
اكثر من 890 مليون ريال في الربع الاول من
العامل الجهري لليوم دخلت الساحه للمملكه
السعوديه الامور كلها تمام خدمات موجوده
متوفره لا يوجد اي رسوم للتحميل وسرعه
التحميل ممتازه كلش كل جوازات مؤخرونه
والتفتيش مؤخرونا والخدمات موتهم
يعني اذا سيارتنا جايه متكاملين ما نتاخر
يعني نص ساعه ربع ساعه او اقل من عشر
دقائق نكمل ما شاء الله يعني نشكرهم عمل
جيد عمل سريع يعني ونجات شغاله نظافه وعمل
مجاني ما شاء الله تبارك الرحمن لا يقتصر
منفذ جديده عرعر عربي منطقه الحدود
الشماليه السعوديه على حركه التجاره
البينيه فقط وانما يستقبل الضيوف الرحمن
من الحجاج والمعتمرين العراقيين وسط
منظومه خدمات متكامله امنيا وصحيا وتقنيا
من منفذ جديده عرعر على الحدود السعوديه
العراقيه
جزاعا ماصي العربيه
ينضم الينا من جده رئيس مجلس الاعمال
السعودي العراقي الدكتور نواف الخربيط
دكتور نواف حياك الله معي فرشاه الرابعه
من الرياض زخم كبير لمجلس التنسيق السعودي
العراقي منذ صباح اليوم على المستوى مجلس
الاعمال الملتقى الاقتصادي ما الذي
انجزتموه على الجانب السعودي من اتفاقيات
اليوم
[موسيقى]
الصادرات العراقيه السعوديه ايضا يعني ما
يقلل
العراقي او الشراكه في في هذا الميزان
الاقتصادي ميزان الشراكه بين البلدين يعني
كم تستهدفون
احنا عملنا مثلا بدينا كل سنه ما شاء الله
يرتفع الثقافه الامنيه بالميه فان شاء
الله الامل انه يكون بخطوه اولى انه بمجرد
ما يرتفع
صادرات عراقيه راح تتوقع انه ممكن يزيد
الى مليار ونص دولار يعني ما يقارب 100 من
حجم الصادرات اللي حيكون ما بين العراق
والسعوديه والسعوديه طيب قبل قليل انت
تحدثت على زياده حجم الصادرات ايضا
العراقيين السعوديه وكفتها الميزان ايضا
احنا نعرف ان هذا المجلس
انشئ عام 2017 كثير من الاجتماعات حدثت
وكثير ايضا من الجلسات واللقاءات بين
الرجال الاعمال ايضا كذلك تمت ما الذي تم
انجازه على مستوى الرجال الاعمال الشق
التجاري والاقتصادي منذ 2017 وحتى اللحظه
كمجلس رجال الاعمال ضبط اجتمعت الاجلتين
مع بعض او يعني صار مجلسين متناظرين مع
بعض ومن سنه ونصف فقط كانت في تقنيه
الاختيار الاعضاء سابقا بالجانب العراقي
اخر تكوين الجانب العراقي للمجلس العراقي
السعودي من جانب العراقي طبعا بدعم من
الامانه العامه مجلس الوزراء تم اجراء
سريع لاختيار الاعضاء وتشكير رئاسه ومجلس
ولجنه التنفيذيه هذا اللي ادى الى الى
انتخابات قرارات الان بما يخص القطاع
الخاص او هذا طبعا مشكور الحكومه السابقه
والحكومه الحاليه بوجود الامانه العامه
على على تفعيل هذا الدور
طيب اخيرا دكتور الشركات العراقيه
التي ترغب بالدخول للسوق السعودي بعتذر
منك انا اعتقد انه كان نهايه الاجابه لكن
الشركات العراقيه اللي الحديث عنها بانها
تحاول الدخول الى السوق السعوديه
والاستثمار ايضا كذلك في المملكه
وش المجالات اللي تركز عليها هذه الشركات
تحديدا
يعني اكثر مبادره الجثه الان من من رجال
الاعمال العراقيين لدخول السوق السعودي
وكذلك الجانب الاخر السعودي للدخول السوق
العراقي
في هذا المنطقه التجاريه الحره اللي حتكون
ما بين عند جيدة عرعر هذه واحده جدا
للمنتج او مصنع بالعراقي والسعودي انه
يدخلون المواد الاوليه او لهذه المنطقه
تطلع المنتج منها للكلى البلدين ايضا
مدعومه كهربائيا بالكهرباء وطاقه يعني
بصوره عامه امنيا فهذه واحده جدا
والمستثمرين اغلبهم يعني طلبوا التفاصيل
هذه المنطقه ايضا بالنسبه للمستثمر
العراقي راح يكون عنده لسته من جانب
العراقي للمستثمرين العراقيين وما
يريدون من الجانب السعودي او يحبون بيه
وندى وكذلك طلبنا من نظرنا السعودي المثل
انه مشاريع
[موسيقى]
القطاع الخاص السعودي اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
جده رئيس مجلس الاعمال السعودي العراقي
الدكتور نوف الغربيه شكرا لك يا دكتور
اكد الامين العام لمجلس التعاون لدول
الخليج العربيه جاسم محمد البديوي حصه
مجلس التعاون على دعم استعاده الامن
والسلامه والاستقرار في اليمن مشددا على
ان الموقف الثابت لمجلس التعاون بشان دعم
الجهود التي تقودها الامم المتحده لانهاء
الازمات اليمنيه وشاد البديوي بالدوري
الرياضي للدول الخليجيه في مساعده الشعب
اليمني خاصه ما يقوم به مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه مشيرا باهميات
اخراج اليمن من ازماته وتحقيق السلام
والحفاظ على وحدته وسيادته لما يمثله
اليمن من عمق استراتيجي
الرابع مستمر وفي بعد قليل
لا كانت انه جميع جميع التهم تم الموافقه
عليها للاستمرار فيها
والد الغريبي المقتول بامريكا يكشف
للعربيه الموافقه على استمرار محاكمه
المتهمه نيكور روجرز
حياكم الله من جديد كشف والد مبتعه الوليد
الغريبي المقتول في الولايات المتحده
للعربيه بعد جلسه الاستماع الاولى في
القضيه كشف انه قد تمت الموافقه على
استمرار المحاكمه بالتهم الخمس الموجهه
للمتهمه نيكول روجرز
الجلسه اساسا فقط
استمراريه المحاكمه يعني تسمح للقاضي تسمح
بانه المحاكمه تستمر ولا لا اذا كان فيها
ترى ان فيها جنايه ولا لا والنتيجه الحمد
لله كانت انه جميع جميع التهم تم الموافقه
عليها للاستمرار فيها الان مرحله
التداول المذكرات بين المحامين وجمع
الادله وعرض على بعض اكيد فيها اخذ وعطاء
فقالت يعني
[موسيقى]
اعطها شهرين ثلاثه
الى اربع شهور اتوقع
فقدمنا طريق طويل الله يعين يعني المحاكمه
يعني باين انه ما هي سهله
توفيت ممتعه سعوديه في ولايه
غرقا وذلك اثر سقوطها من جرف صخري اعلى
نهر في ولايه كانسيس الامريكيه ابن عمي
المتوفيه اثير الخلبان كشف للعربيه لم تعد
الى السعوديه منذ عام بسبب دراستها وانها
ذهبت للابتعاد برفقه شقيقها مضيفا انها
توفيت بعد ان سقطت في النهر خلال رحله مع
صديقاتها
اعلنت الهيئه الملكيه لمحافظه العلا تسجيل
جبل عكمه في سجل ذاكره العالم التابع
لمنظمه الامم المتحده للتربيه والعلوم
والثقافه حيث يعد جبل عكمه احد ابرز
المواقع التاريخيه في محافظه العلا والذي
يصنف كاكبر المكتبات المفتوحه في الجزيره
العربيه كونه يضم المئات من النقوش
الاثريه والمنحوتات الحجريه
وتنضم الينا مديره المسوحات الاثريه في
الهيئه الملكيه لمحافظه العلى والرئيس
المشارك لمشروع خيبر عبر العصور الدكتوره
منيره المشوح دكتوره حياك الله معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض وخلينا نسال اولا
عن
هذا التسجيل تسجيل جبل عكمه في يعني ذاكره
العالم التابعه لليونسكو ما الذي يعني
اهلا وسهلا بكم جميعا نسعد اليوم بهذا
الانجاز الوطني الكبير الذي يعزز صدقا
مكانه المملكه ثقافيا
ويؤكد التزام الهيئه الملكيه بمحافظه
العلى على تحقيق تطلعات الرؤيه 2030
موقعك ما يجسد احد اهم الاصول التراثيه
على مستوى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
يقع في منطقه جوهريه ضمن حدود مملكه دادان
والاحيان القديمه
ويتميز بوجود مئات من النقوش المهمه في
نطاق مكاني واحد وبجوده حفظ استثنائيه
جعلت صراحه اهميه الموقع تتجاوز الحدود
الوطنيه والاقليميه الى المستوى العالمي
جداره ضمن ذاكره العالم للتراث الوثائقي
ممتاز المعلومات التاريخيه اللي اللي تم
استقراؤها من هذه النقوش اللي تحدثنا انها
موجوده في جبل عكمه
العديد من المعلومات يعني موقع جبل عكمه
في نقوش كثير بعضها يعود لملوك مملكه
الاحيان البعض الاخر للعامه وجزء منها حتى
للنساء في المجتمع اللحياني ما يصير لدور
المراه الاحيانيه ودور الممالك العربيه
القديمه في رحله تمكين المراه قبل الاف
السنين وبالتالي تاثير ذلك على رحله
التمكين على المستوى العالمي للبشريه
النقوش كشفت عن عن الحياه الاجتماعيه
اهميه النخيل الامطار المحاصيل الزراعيه
المجتمع اللحياني في واحه العلا اهميه حتى
الحياه الدينيه واهميه الدعاء لذو غيبه هو
الاله الكبير في مملكه دادان
النقوش لا تعكس صدقا يعني بس
مدى تطور المجتمع اللحياني كمجتمع مدني بل
تعكس كذلك براعه الخطاط اللحياني تنحت
والسمات الفنيه المتقدمه لتلك الشعوب التي
استوطنت
تعتبر النقوش متميزه لكن ابرزها في وجهه
نظري 24 نقش نحتها الفنان بمهاره تستوجب
الاشاده يعني نحتها بشكل بارز
ان تتخيل يعني اخي ان
تنحت نحت بارز لعده سطور وعشرات الكلمات
على صخر ويكون هامش الخطا عندك صفر
فاحنا ما نتحدث صراحه عن ازمير وطرق
ومهاره نحت عاديه نتحدث عن علم واجمان
بطبيعه الصخور وكيفيه التعامل معها
لتجنب تصدعاتها
فهذا بشكل عام ما جعل
يتميز على المستوى العالمي اشكرك جزيل
الشكر بالتوفيق لكم الدكتور منيره المشوح
مديره المساحات الاثريه في الهيئه الملكيه
لمحافظه العلى
انطلقت في مدينه جازان جنوب السعوديه
فعاليات مهرجان المانجو والفواكه
الاستوائيه للعام الجاري وذلك بمشاركته 53
مزارعا يقدمون اطيب انواع المانجو
والفواكه الاستوائيه الاخرى التي تشتهر
بها المنطقه حيث يهدف المهرجان الى
استثمار امكانات منطقه جازان الزراعيه
ودعم المزارعين وتحفيزهم لمزيد من
الانتاجات الزراعيه ذات الجدول الاقتصاديه
العاليه
من جازان نظامه لدينا مراسل عربيه اسامه
القاسم اسامه مرحبا بك معي في نشاط
الرابعه من الرياض وخلينا نحكي عن الكميات
الانتاج هذا هذا العام اسامه كيف يمكن
الحديث عنها وخلينا في المانجو اول مش
الفواكه الثاني
اهلا وسهلا طيب على مشاهدينا العربيه
نعمان المانجو والفواكه الاستوائيه في
جازان اذا نتحدث اليوم عن اكثر من 60 صنف
نجحت زراعتها اليوم في جازان المتواجده
اليوم التي يتم استهلاكها وتصديرها حوالي
30 صنف تقريبا ساتحدث بدايه عن مفارقه
حصلت ان عام 2005 كانت عدد الاشجار
الموجوده في منطقه الجزاء لا تتجاوز 250
الف شجره بانتاج لا يتجاوز ايضا ثمانيه
عشره الف طن اليوم نتحدث في بدايه عام
2023 عن اكثر من مليون مليون شتله وشجره
مانجو موزعه على اكثر من 19 الف مزرعات
تصدر اكثر من 65 الف طن من المانجو سنويا
نتحدث اليوم اذا عن ما الذي جعل جازان
اليوم ارضا خصبه للمانجو بشكل خاص وايضا
فواكه استوائيه بشكل عام البيئه التي
تتواجد بها منطقه جزاء على مستوى التربه
الخصبه وايضا المياه الج التي تغذي اشجار
المانجو طبعا جازان تحوي اكبر مزرعه
للمانجو في السعوديه واحدى اكبر مزارع
المانجو في الشرق الاوسط ان لم تكن اكبرها
تنتج اكثر من اربعه الاف طن سنويا هذه فقط
مزرعه غير حديثنا ايضا عن المزارع الكثيره
المانجو اليوم في جازان بالتاكيد تاتي ضمن
موسم جاذب جدا للزوار والسائحين نتحدث على
ان جازان هذه الايام تشهد ايضا امطارا
متواتره خصوصا مع موسم الغبار ما جعل ايضا
موسم المانغو ياتي في وقت مطير جدا ما
يعزز ايضا استهلاك كبير جدا لاشجار
المانجو المانجو هنا في جازان واعتقد ايضا
انه في السعوديه بشكل عام تحظى بشعبيه
كبيره هي الفاكهه الملكيه التي يعني
تقريبا الكل يستمتع باستهلاك يتحدث اليوم
اذا عن هذه الاطنان وهذه الاصناف
المتواجده الان بالشاشه اذا ما الذي ايضا
جعل جازان اليوم محطه استهلاك كبير جدا
للفواكه الاستوائيه ايضا بالاضافه الى
المانجو ارضيتها الخصبه ايضا التنوع
التضاريس على المستوى الزراعي يتحدث عن
مناطق جبليه تهاميه ساحليه ما جعلها
بالتاكيد تنتج اكثر عدد ممكن من المنتجات
ما جعلها اليوم سله غذاء السعوديه ان
نتحدث ايضا على ان كما اسبقت الاصناف
المتوزعه اليوم والمستهلكه والمصدره حوالي
30 صنف الستين صنف التي تم ذكرها من قبل
الجهات هي اصناف تم نجاح زراعتها اليوم في
جازان ما يعني اننا ايضا قد نشاهدها في
السنوات القادمه تباع وتصدر
وتستهلك بشكل كبير جدا المانجو اليوم في
هذه الفتره تقريبا فتره شهرين هي فتره
تشهد فيها ثمره المانجو استهلاكا كبيرا
يعني تقريبا من مصدر مسؤول هنا في
المهرجان ان المانجو في غضون اسبوع واحد
تنتهي جميع الاطنان المتواجده هنا في
المهرجان سواء على المستوى التصدير او حتى
على مستوى الاستهلاك تحدثنا اليوم جازان
فقط وهي كم تقارع دول كبيره جدا في انتاج
اطنان المانجو هي اصناف جدا عاليه اهم
الاصناف الموجوده اليوم
وايضا التومي والكثير من الاصناف اليوم
التي يتم استهلاكها وتصديرها بشكل متواصل
مرجع اليوم في اكثر من 53 مزارع اكثر من
مزرعه متواجده اليوم باجود انواع المانجو
ايضا فواكه السويله ومتحدث عن الكاكاو
نتحدث ايضا عن البشر وتحدث ايضا اليوم
ايضا عن الجوافه ونتحدث ايضا عن التين
والموز البلدي المتواجد هنا في اجازه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل الصوره اللي نقلتها لنا من جزاء
مراسل العربيه وسام القاسم
[موسيقى]
الرابعه مستمره وفي بعد قليل
الطلاب والطالبات يجرون من الرياض اتصالا
برايدي الفضائيين وعلي في المحطه الدوليه
حياكم الله من جديد اجراء عدد من الطلاب
والطالبات في السعوديه اتصال اللاسلكيا
الفضاء السعوديين
برناوي وعلي القرني في محطه الفضاء
الدوليه وذلك من محطه ارضيه بالعاصمه
الرياض نتابع
هوتيل
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم انا اسمي هاشم مراد السؤال
هو
اهلا الله
يعطيكم ونخطط لها مسبقائنا في الغالب بعده
ايام قبل تنفيذها
فصل الصيف سيكون اطول على غير عادته هذا
العام التفاصيل في تقويم
[موسيقى]
يحصل احيانا في بعض السنين ان الخط
المناخي يتزحزح عن المعتاد بمعنى ان فصل
الصيفي او الشتاء يتقدم او يتاخر او يتمطر
بعض شيء وهذا امر طبيعي ومعتاد ويحصل على
سنوات متقاربه كما يحصل الان ففصل الشتاء
انتهى ولا ونحن الان نعيش في اول فصل
الصيف لكن اثار موسم الشتاء تنتابنا بين
ان واخر خاصه على المناطق الشماليه فبعض
السنين يرتفع حمو المحيط وتنخفض درجات
الحراره على الاقطاب فيؤثر هذا على تقدم
وتاخر الفصول والمواسم وعلى اي حال فان
فصل الصيف لهذه السنه سيطول على غير عادته
بمعنى انه يبي يدخل علينا موسم الوسم
والصيف ما زال شاد علينا حلمت ان زمان
صيفي منصرم واله حققت الايام رؤياك رايت
احلام اهل الحب كلهم لما مثلت امامي عند
شباكك
[تصفيق]
وفصل الصيف يبدا مع كنه ثريا وينتهي بموسم
مرخيات
كانه ثريا اربعين يوما مربحانيه القيظ
اربعين يوما زدحت القيض 26 يوما وجمره
القيظ 26 يوما وبعدها يدخل علينا موسم
مرخيات كذا الصيف عن جرد السبايا ولا بقى
من الغيظ الا مرخيات
القرائد
[موسيقى]
ختم رابعتي بابرز عناوينها
البيان الختامي لمجلس التنسيق السعودي
العراقي يؤكد على توسيع وتعزيز التعاون
بين البلدين
مجلس التعاون الخليجي يجدد التاكيد على
دعمه جهود انهاء الازمه اليمنيه عبر الحل
السياسي
سعوديه في ولايه كانسيس الامريكيه وقريب
لها يكشف تفاصيل حادثه غرقها
جبل عكمه احد ابرز مواقع العلى التاريخيه
يدخل سجل ذاكره العالم التابع لليونسكو
ومانجو جازان تغزل الاسواق الاقليميه
باكثر من 60 صفا من خلال مليون شجره
شكرا لكم على كرمه لطفي للمتابعه الرابعه
انتهت الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات